boy i had my doubts but after seeing
tom holland do a front flip over a ledge
i'm
totally convinced he could play the new
spider-man
if only everyone had such amazing
agility
whatever i'll give him a pass if he
throws on some thick rimmed dork glasses
and gets a haircut
i hope he appreciates what he's got a
lot of people would
kill to feel like they were spider-man
which is what all the video games are
for
hell i've played almost every single one
and there's just something that's so
hard to capture about
being spider-man i mean we already have
a game about
being the batman why isn't there one
about being spider-man
there just hasn't been a definitive
spider-man game where
everyone raves about how perfect it is
it waits excitedly until the sequel
releases a few years later
people want to complain about the movies
rebooting every five minutes try being a
fan of these damn video games
maybe we did get the definitive game and
they just rebooted right away so we
couldn't focus on it
maybe there's one that's been overlooked
and really nailed it
let's look back through the history of
dead uncle simulators and see if any of
them got it right
this is my retrospective of the
spider-man games
instead of talking [ __ ] about movies
that haven't come out yet
i'll be doing something a little less
formal
you hear that hannigan i'm not gonna use
your fancy words and economic knowledge
put your no funnel out sign away i'm
taking over this space party
[Music]
so about the video games what were they
all like
well the first one on this list holds a
special place in my heart
the playstation one spider-man game
titled the
the spider-man
this one was my childhood if i wasn't
watching my dad play it over
and over because i told him to i was
struggling to learn how to play it
myself
it was pretty much my introduction to
the character because i was exposed to
it at like
age two it was the first third person
action game featuring spider-man
there were others before it that were
side-scrollers or beat-em-ups and
garbage but this one broke the mold it
starts spider-man talking like a spanish
police officer and stopping a plan to
infest all of new york with symbiotes
what is this the bad guy olympics look
times square is on the way to omnitech
let's find out what venom's up to and
then we'll tackle rhino
alongside the titular character a
kick-ass cast of villains and heroes
with plastic faces
venom was pretty much the only character
with a moving jaw
and he was voiced by cosmo i found that
out like a month ago and it blew my mind
where'd spider was
come out and play
in terms of gameplay it's pretty clunky
by today's standards but back then
this was the [ __ ] the simplicity has a
charm you
jump you swing you kick you punch you
listen to yourself make jokes
[Applause]
it seems to pretty much hit the mark
right but it's got its weaknesses the
story is pretty corny even by comic book
standards and the limitations of the
technology hold it back a lot
spider-man's costume is wrong because it
was too hard to animate or
he just didn't feel like using a sharpie
to put the webs on that day
you can only do two consecutive swings
before spider-man remembers that uncle
ben's death was all his fault and the
game forces you to watch as he allows
himself to be consumed by the cold
embrace of death
but this game was hardcore all the
graphical setbacks and simplistic design
choices may have been standard fare then
but it doesn't age well
it had a sequel a year later that was
pretty much the same thing with slightly
better graphics
and a less interesting lineup of boss
fights
it was called spider-man 2 enter electro
in which spider-man sticks a fork in an
electrical socket because mary jane
miscarried their daughter
and then he watched his clone die
horribly
oh oh wait did that get retconned
oh okay don't worry everyone i got don't
worry everyone it's fine it got
retconned
doesn't matter at least this one had the
costume right
and much like the last one it has pretty
high replay value because you get a new
costume every time you beat it and you
always want to see what the new one does
until you get that one that makes you
invincible in which case never mind
stop playing tease that one of my
favorite obscure villains is in this
game the beatle
who's like an evil iron man i was so
ready to have an epic battle sequence
with him on top of a train and then oh
never mind
he just flies away fine i'll have an
epic battle with electro you
coward oh yeah the final mission was
heavily edited because it was supposed
to take place on top of the world trade
center and this came out in 2001
as you can imagine they couldn't get the
rights to it because a giant electrical
power station on top of the building was
incredibly inaccurate and the owners of
the building didn't want to be so
grossly misrepresented as supporting the
growing non-renewable energy crisis in
america
spider-man the movie game i guess
a bigger step in the right direction was
the movie licensed game
spider-man just
spider-man well [ __ ] i bet that caused
some confusion for a store clerk
somewhere
this game features the voices of the
spider-man movie from the same year and
the same
general plot but with more dumb stuff
like giant robots and a whole bunch of
unrelated villains just showing up
because in this one you can swing on a
web more than twice
the fact that that is an achievement
worth of note is kind of sad
but other than that it's exactly the
same as those other two games
pretty boring overall experience
it didn't do anything really new or
exciting from the other two
just improved on them in small ways
which deserves a bit of praise on its
own
in the end this one doesn't really feel
like you are spider-man
just that you're playing the movie this
was inspired by
then things get interesting in
spider-man 2 enter electra 08
this is the big one not only is it
listed as one of the best spider-man
games
it is listed as one of the best movie
tie-in
and best superhero games not only does
it follow the plot of the movie
but it also expands upon it and features
side stories that really get spider-man
right as a character
did she say jameson
someone shoot me now
stalking girls now that's pretty
pathetic don't you think
or is she on your naughty list too
not exactly what do you care anyway
no reason i'm just dropping by to say hi
he gets to go on team ups with black cat
and see a world where he doesn't have
all the problems he does as peter parker
he's tempted with being irresponsible
and giving up on mary jane as his true
love
but in the end he realizes that his
responsibility makes him who he is and
new york needs spider-man to be on the
up and up
no matter how much i might wish things
were different
there's only one spider-man gameplay is
nothing short of magnificent
with combat that you can almost point to
as the inspiration for arkham's counter
dodge button
why does batman have spider sense and
the best part of it all
bruce campbell is there to call you
names for being bad at the game
you don't actually jump until you've let
go of the jump button
okay now go jump in a lake
if you tap the jump button you'll just
do a little
hop a little a little hop
that's because you didn't charge your
jump am i going too fast for you
he was there on the other one but that
was like a missable extra mode
this one is part of the plot it's the
first thing that happens
oh and swinging physics and open world
with whatever bruce campbell was there
okay in all seriousness this one broke
new ground with the swinging physics and
exploration
i mean it was like gta with spider-man
the combat was refined the bosses were
great and the story was surprisingly
well thought out
the problems lie in the fact that it
gets a little tedious after a while
and it still hadn't perfected all of its
new ideas
it should be praised for having new
ideas alone but they just needed
more iterations and tweaks the swinging
is fun
and never gets old but after a while it
really gets old
i still have a hard time getting
anywhere quick with it i've been
practicing for 11 years
i just can't get high up enough and i
always end up
running along the ground or jumping with
how often you can't make it past two
stories
maybe i just suck at it who knows before
you get to do anything really fun with
the story you have to go solve random
street crimes
you walk to the random person with a
green question mark over their head they
[ __ ] and moan about how their life
isn't perfect and they thought things
would be better after college but they
weren't
then you go do some kind of annoying
little task rinse
repeat for what feels like ever
oh god i'm so tired of getting that
little kid's
[ __ ] balloon back why are they making
me do this
god damn kid you know how many people
have died
because i was using my godlike abilities
to get you a two-dollar piece of rubber
you should be ashamed of yourself i bet
there's a rape victim out there
lying broken and violated in an alley
wondering where spider-man is and i'm
here
getting you a balloon you know what
[ __ ] you it's my balloon now
so it gets a little irritating and
repetitive and the final boss is like a
dark souls enemy
i died so many
times there was a lot of great new ideas
here and this is definitely the base
that i think all spider-man games should
build upon
but they didn't focus on the fun factor
if only
they had like an extra gimmick in the
next one
an extra character to play as maybe a
more menacing villain
and maybe more fun stuff to do in the
city rather than just waste all of your
daily bugle money at the arcade
thusly the next incarnation of
spider-man video games was born
ultimate spider-man no relation to the
awful cartoon
this game has a story so good that they
eventually took it into the canon of the
book
ultimate spider-man several years later
take that arkham we won this round
we're considered canon
what is it i i have no idea
what are those black things yeah that's
the
i have no idea part mostly
you know everything up until like the
last 10
where's your validation by source
material huh
fine why don't you go run off and tell
under the red hood again but dumber you
washed up hack
so i can't say much on it other than go
play it and experience it for yourself
or read these dumb books for nerds
gameplay-wise you do things pretty
similarly to spider-man 2 but with the
addition of being
switched at random intervals in the
story to playing as spider-man's
arch-nemesis
venom played by eminem yes
he is the arch-nemesis not the
drug-addicted businessman or the soul
stealing fat guy with prosthetic arms
venom is where the real party's at all
right
let's finish this up
like hell i got dibs he can throw
cars eat people throw people and not eat
cars
[Music]
you know what he doesn't take [ __ ] from
little kids with balloons
damn he just killed a child by sucking
the vital fluids out of his organs and
left his husk lying in the street
this game's [ __ ] awesome
he's almost hilariously overpowered in
this game
fatality he's so badass he even knocks
wolverine around like hank does to janet
something the hulk couldn't do what the
hell but then spider-man beats him at
the end
does that mean spider-man's stronger
than the guy who's stronger than the guy
strong enough to fight the hulk
never mind
it uses this great cel-shaded art style
reminiscent of the book it's based on
so the graphics still look good by
today's standards if the walking dead
gets away with it
so does this one in this game you have a
little more
fine-tuning to the odd jobs for
spider-man to complete
and just helping people in general the
goal isn't
always to punch the cool boss in the
face but mostly to just help the guy who
got caught up in the superhero battle
spidey really shows that he cares about
average joe on the street
and look i get that boss fight with
beetle
all right you armor-plated scrub it's
time that
what what he left again
damn it where'd he go where did he go
no seriously
[Music]
well that just figures
hey i know you get this all the time but
any of you see a big scary robot guy
with a backpack
doing fun spider-man stuff that doesn't
involve murder
is pretty fun too including racing the
human torch with the swinging physics
doing the little side mission things
actually isn't as frustrating
because it tells you a set number of
them you can do before you can progress
in the story
they don't have as much variety but
they're considerably easier
and even really fun plus if you don't
feel like wasting that much time between
missions on them
you can just grind them out in one
session of like 25 acts of kindness to
appease the spider-man gods
and they'll never ask you about it again
web swinging is a lot of fun it feels a
little sluggish at first but the speed
actually helps you to learn how to
maneuver around better
so when it gets much faster later you
know how to do it
when the time comes you're gonna use
that spider agility to dodge a fireball
the combat appears pretty basic just
punch and kick
you can actually get really creative
with it like when spider-man's bouncing
off the walls and throwing people around
with the webs
you can use this badassery to follow
missions where you chase strings of
unique gangs and sometimes you can even
bump into a low-level super villain on
the street and kick him in the teeth
i think this is the best one of the
playstation 2 era
it has everything it needs to be awesome
and i highly recommend you get away to
check this one out
whenever i ask people about this one
even die hard spidey fans
they usually don't remember this game i
say ultimate spider-man is a criminally
overlooked
classic and he'll come to you of his own
free will
oh i don't think we have to worry about
that
what the hell are you doing
[Music]
and i think they even ripped off one of
the boss fights with electro to turn it
into a scene from the second amazing
spider-man movie it was way cooler here
though
this is the real jumping-off point for
these games we get a little better every
time and now we're here
nowhere to go but up i can't wait to see
where they go next
how can they beat this one it's gonna be
awesome
oh no
oh well i'm not looking forward to that
[Music]
tune in next time true believers you
won't want to believe it's
[Music]
true
the venom marathon continues on the
biggest tv in new york
you just want to stand there thinking
about it